uh sorry you walked several questions
yeah so do you guys think it's okay to
leave a relationship or a family if
you're not happy so if you have kids
you get a little help
also guys let me know in the chat what
mic is like off because i keep saying
that a mic is off and i'm not sure which
one it is
um so let me know which one and i'll see
if i can fix it but i think these three
are okay so i think it's either mine or
yours
but go ahead are you leaving
[Music]
wait are you down here
[Music]
but it's not going to be the same for
the kids like there's nothing like
having not been unhappy for
i guess they're going back and forth and
it's working out and you keep arguing
for a year yeah i think if like you're
not happy yeah i think i think it's fine
for evil party to leave if like
the party isn't happy i need like three
conversations i think a lot of people
stay because of the kids that will make
sure you like
we tried to choose didn't work cool
that's three three situations okay
i feel like when it comes to kids you
have to kind of think about them as well
because
like a lot of kids come from families
that don't have like me i came from a
family that didn't have two parents and
growing up like that is like
growing up like that it's kind of um
like a disadvantage so loads of things
in life and i'm just like if i have kids
i feel like
sometimes i may put them first like
until they get to like around the age of
18 i might put their feelings first and
they're like i'll try to make it work as
much as i can with my partner but i'd
rather us be living in the same
household and like for the kids
that affects you as a parent like see
how i think of it it's like okay cool
we've tried everything yeah we've had
everything to make it work okay we're
actually unhappy for one to three years
and then is it working yeah so i'm going
to make a quick change so i'm going to
take off your mic and you two are going
to share because i think this is picking
up the echo and i haven't
yeah so you two are just going to go
back and forth sorry
um sorry
okay yeah go ahead go ahead yeah so i so
i just feel like
um for me to be the best person i can
for my
for my kids is like
i need to be like a better person for
myself and if i'm unhappy like i feel
like that shows him with my relationship
with my kids that they're going to see
it in the house they're going to sense
that i just i think so why am i just
trying to please them and give them
false hope and we could really prepare
them and have certain conversations with
the kids
because it's like not everything does
work out hunky-dory and you can have two
parents that live in the same household
like we could me and my partner could
really co-parent if we have the open
communication but the problem i just
feel like when you have kids it's not
about you anymore like it's not it's not
about your happiness it's about the kids
and i think like it's women mostly like
leave relationships if you're college
educated you know what your chance of
getting divorced is if you're a girl
[Music]
no no you're gonna leave 90 like you if
you get divorced and you're college
educated well women only leave 10
percent of the time or they leave 90 of
the time
yeah that's a statistic yeah and it's um
it's 70 depending on the source 70 to 80
of the time in just normal relationships
like women are the ones leaving not men
but like i feel like women often like
leave because we're not happy for like a
short period of time so thinking of like
the long term
yeah but i think men are weak i think
men are weak
guys one at a time shots fired but i
think men are weak in the fact of
like they're happy to stay
like if they just maybe if
i don't know like why would they be
happy to stay no no no no no no
no but you're not able to come to the
table and say i'm not happy so instead
you step out
our emotions beforehand i don't think i
think a lot of men struggle to say that
in general or to hurt her feelings
somebody that you love and then to say
look i'm not really happy but then what
you do is you go do something dumb and
then you get yourself in trouble so then
she leaves you
and you don't leave the situation hence
why that statistic is so high i think
men are just dumb in a lot of situations
so it's not like they but one's enough
enough like you lot of humans your
brains are very smart and it's not okay
to be like and then you're just dumb you
sound dumb saying that just excuse me
i didn't mean it
no so so if you're gonna talk into that
mic like grab the stand and just pass it
between the two of you does that make
sense i can make this longer sorry we've
got issues today
go ahead okay
so the original question stay that
against these no i'm just
gonna think of this so no the original
question is like
it's like when you have kids is it about
your happiness or is it about the kids
happiness
i think it kind of can play a role as
water because if
you stay together you could actually be
bringing like more of a toxic
environment so if you stay together like
pure arguments right
it could end up just getting like and i
guess if it is
toxic like that naturally it can get
like i guess a bit manipulative it's
just like
maybe if you break up it might be a
better relationship actually might be
better for the kids if you actually
separate because you can then
live a better life as a as a family can
i follow up on that i agree with what he
said because i feel like also like even
when you bring up your kids in that
environment you're kind of showing your
kids what they're going to want to
accept in the future like personally me
like i want to show my kids like a way
of living and i feel like
if i'm showing them that yeah i'm
staying in like an unhappy relationship
because they're going to sense it we all
live in the same house like how are you
not like my kids aren't going to be
stupid
like so for me it's like i'm showing
them oh it's okay to stay in an unhappy
marriage but i don't want my kids to
feel like that just because you're
obliged to your kids like because you
could really teach their moles like just
because we're co-parenting and we're
separated or divorced et cetera doesn't
mean but you really statistically like
how much of a disadvantage you are if
you don't have both parents in the house
even if you're dividing like really good
yeah like you're still at a disadvantage
because it's not the same
no it's like but i'm gonna be honest i
don't i don't i don't i don't know them
like these stats off the top of my head
but like you're much more likely to
commit a crime if you're not raised with
both parents in the house you're much
more likely to drop out of school like
every stat that possible like i promise
if you spend five minutes researching
this like
is
it says it's better to have both parents
in the house
so entry
you're you us but i would be shocked if
it's different here i would be shocked
but then statistically more people get
divorced in the u.s than the uk in
general like is that true for sure
do you think it's because less people
get married here do you think because
because um the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31 where it's 27
in the us for women anyway
i just
30 31
in the uk for average age of first
marriage well i i know obviously i'm not
statistic i don't know if it's like
taken into account because obviously
like if it is a broken home it could be
possible like
one of the parents might be just gone
you know i'm saying so like
all the people that maybe like
are living like the single parent life
obviously maybe that is a disadvantage
but
the if the both parents were there
contributing like i'm being i guess
being role models in that way
i feel like
maybe the statistics won't reflect that
as such
um i mean it probably i'm sure it's
better like
if the dad or the mom like whatever one
is out of the house like is in their
life
but
i just can't imagine a world where like
it's better to have
them in separate houses than into one
one picture
like it doesn't mean the child's like
doomed it can't do anything it's just
like if you leave you're putting your
kids at every statistical disadvantage
possible and it's for what you for your
happiness but you're supposed to love
your kids more than you like if we're in
a relationship and we're not happy i
feel like the thing that we could agree
on is our children's happiness and we're
going to try to figure out stuff for our
children's happiness too yeah yeah
that's what that's the relationship but
then also it's like you have to at what
point you consider your own happiness
you have your own one life like i
honestly huh of course you have your
kids no listen but it's not like they're
going to be
like it's not like the world is at end
like they can't move on you have your
mom you have your dad they're not
together but like
on a daily basis with someone that is
obviously the reason you're unhappy with
them they've ever hurted you or like
hurt you know her
[Music]
man i ever heard you're like something's
happened to cause like this rift in
like seriousness but do you think that
possibly like it's something that you
yourself have to work on because it
takes two in a relationship
so if you're arguing all the time like
it takes someone to argue with of course
but you'd be unhappy in something in the
situation not about yourself you'd be
like because that's something you would
address with your partner like oh i
don't like this about myself or i don't
think like they would argue about yo
you're not doing this or
get to them
you'll get like we'll get mad petty
people like when you don't like
something about someone else if you
really care about someone you're like i
have like you don't want to see them
angry at you you put your own i've been
in society at the start yeah but
obviously like if we're talking about
what would have happened with someone
about doing this for 18 years above
being unhappy for 18 years the ten year
10-year hits from like it's mad bro like
man's arguing about the craziest things
that's ah
the craziest things like things are so
irrelevant 10 years in your life like
i just don't think things are forever
like i think it shouldn't be like
yeah marriage for well seriously i think
like at five
i think no no no i mean more in the fact
of like every five years like kind of
sit down if kids are involved or not
just like are you happy can i do
anything more what is what's good in our
relationship what's bad in our
relationship this whole
happy forever is just a person i think
it's a fairy tale i've been married i've
been married
i believe in it yeah and i tried to stay
in my marriage so and would i get
married again absolutely so i'm saying
would you think like you just said like
as in like you wouldn't stay with that
person like you made it sound like you'd
rethink like no i just think no i'm
saying i'm saying conversations yeah i'm
saying in a marriage and any even in a
relationship doesn't even have to get to
a marriage point even with your
girlfriend you're free four five years
in and you're like
you know and i think this is a nice way
for men to come to the table like
actually you're not doing this how you
used to or and this is the comfortable
bit or i would like you to do this or i
really enjoy this we need to go on dates
more we need to go out like i think
that's where the comfortable bit comes
in of the years you start to lose
yourself you gain a hundred pounds never
gonna hurt i feel like that comes in
just like really no relationships in
general more so but she's like
progressing into that marriage yeah
still continue that yeah because when
you're married for ten years like you're
not saying like you're questioning like
but when you're married for ten years
that you this is a part of your routine
like it's a part you wouldn't get that
unhappy before you i think that's why
she's like emphasizing on that
comfortability so she's saying like
going into that like in the process of
going into marriage and even after
marriage like 10 years in like continue
having those conversations because it's
good to be updated
how your husband or wife feels um like
what they think and what their where
their thoughts are because you know as
people but actually we evolve each day
we evolve like ev all the time so maybe
my likes have changed maybe my dislikes
have changed so i think it's good to
like have those open conversations i
have that open line of community